the makeup of colombia's new congress
couldn't be more different than the
previous one for the first time in
history a progressive coalition is the
largest political bloc in both chambers
it's the result of unprecedented
elections that will bring a true leftist
gustavo petro in power in august
this is a historic congress for a number
of reasons first more than 60 percent of
representatives are new it's an
important renovation second it's diverse
with more indigenous representatives
that come from rural colombia and
finally for the first time 30 percent
are women this is very promising
but inauguration was fraught with
controversy outgoing president ivan duke
delivered a feisty speech defending his
accomplishments during his tenure
despite abysmal polling numbers around
20
he attacked the incoming majority saying
that they could put people's private
property at risk
it is possible to have social justice in
remote areas without expropriations and
prejudice and we offered an inflexible
compromise to peace with legality that
advanced in the territories
he was repeatedly interrupted by new
congress representatives they called him
a liar for saying he supported the
implementation of the peace deal and the
protection of social leaders who were
killed in unprecedented numbers during
duca's administration
the new congress is tasked with an
ambitious reform agenda to combat
poverty and inequality
this includes a major tax reform to fund
social programs and long postponed land
pension and police reforms
to do so petra has built a coalition
with centuries parties that should
assure him a majority
experts believe he will take advantage
of a honeymoon period few of his
predecessors had
for the first time we will have the
possibility of
getting through congress radical reforms
coming from the left
nevertheless given the fact that this is
a majority coalition and not a governing
coalition from the left wing party
those reforms will have to be tempered
down in order to be able to pass through
congress
the question now is just how long will
that honeymoon last given the fact that
the country is going through difficult
economic times with high inflation high
unemployment among other issue in an
electorate that's been demanding change
and reform quickly and surely alessandra
ampietti al jazeera bogota